The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I'd like
to begin by reviewing
the last lecture,
where we introduced
the idea of
non-Euclidean spaces.
The important idea here is that
general relativity describes
gravity as a distortion
of space and time.
And that idea becomes
crucial in cosmology,
so we want to understand
what that's about.
As I explained last
time, there are really
two aspects to this
general subject.
There's the question of, how
do we treat curved spacetimes
and how do particles,
for example, behave
when they move through
curved spacetimes.
That we will be doing.
There's also the
important question
of how does matter distort
the spacetime, which
is the Einstein field equations.
That we will not do.
That we will leave for the
general relativity course
that you may or may not want
to take at some point, or maybe
you already have.
The idea of non
Euclidean geometry
really goes back
to Euclid himself,
and the fifth postulate.
The distinction between
Euclidean geometry and what
is generally called non
Euclidean geometry is entirely
in the fifth postulate.
We never bothered changing
the first four postulates.
This fifth postulate
is explained better
in the next slide,
where we have a diagram.
The fifth postulate says that
if a straight line falls on
to other straight lines,
such that the sum of the two
included angles is
less than pi, then
these two lines will
meet on the same side
where the sum of the
angles is less than pi,
and will not meet
on the other side.
This postulate was something
that attracted attention,
really from the very
beginning, because it
seems like a much more
complicated postulate
than the other four.
And for many years,
mathematicians
tried to derive this
postulate from the others,
thinking that it couldn't really
be a fundamental postulate.
But that never worked, and
eventually in the 17 and 1800s,
mathematicians realized that
the postulate was independent.
And you could either assume
it's true or assume it's false.
And you get different versions
of geometry in the two cases.
We learned last time that there
are four other ways, at least,
of stating the things that
are equivalent to the fifth
postulate, and they're
diagrammed here.
If a straight line intersects
one of two parallel lines,
it will also
intersect the other.
If one has a straight
line and another point,
there is one and only one line
through that point, parallel
to the original line.
If one has a figure,
one can construct
a figure which is similar
to it, of any size.
And finally, the
famous statement
about sum of the
angles that make up
the vertices of a triangle.
If there exists just one
triangle for which it's
180 degrees, then
that's equivalent
to the fifth
postulate, and you can
prove that every
triangle has 180 degrees.
The fifth postulate was
questioned in a serious way
by Giovanni Geralamo
Saccheri in the 16, 1700s,
who wrote a detailed study of
what geometry would be like
if the fifth
postulate were false.
He wrote this believing that the
fifth postulate must be true.
And he was looking for a
contradiction, which he never
found.
Things went further in the later
1700s, with Gauss and Bolyai
and Lobachevski, who
independently developed
the geometry that we call
Gauss Bolyai Lobachevski
geometry, which is a two
dimensional geometry,
non Euclidean.
It corresponds to what we
now call an open universe,
that we'll be learning about
in more detail later today.
The Gauss Bolyai
Lobachevski geometry
was treated purely axiomatically
by the three authors
that I just mentioned.
But it was given a
coordinate representation
by Felix Klein in
1870, which was really
the first demonstration
that it really existed.
When one treats
it axiomatically,
one still always
has the possibility
that some contradiction
could be found someplace.
But by the time you put it
into algebraic equations,
then it becomes as consistent
as our understanding
of the real numbers, which
we have a lot of confidence
in, even though I don't
think mathematicians really
know how to prove the
consistency of anything.
But we have a lot of confidence
in this kind of mathematics.
So by 1870, it was
absolutely clear
that this open geometry,
this non-Euclidean geometry,
was a perfectly consistent,
is a perfectly consistent,
formulation of geometry.
An important development
coming out of Kline's work
is that the idea about
how one describes geometry
changed dramatically.
Prior to Kline,
essentially all of geometry
was done in the same
way that Euclid did it,
by writing down axioms
and then proving theorems.
Kline realized that you
could gain a lot of mileage
by taking advantage of our
understanding of algebra
and calculus by describing
things in terms of functions.
And in particular,
geometry is described
by giving a distance
function between points.
This was further
developed by Gauss,
who realized that
distances are additive.
So if distances mean
anything like what
we think distances
mean, it would
be sufficient to describe
the distance between any two
arbitrarily close points.
And then if you want to know
the distance between two
distant points, you draw
a line between them,
and measure the
length of that line
by adding up an infinite number
of infinitesimal segments.
So the idea that distances need
only be defined infinitesimally
was very crucial to our current
understanding of geometry.
Gauss also introduced
another important idea,
which is a restriction on what
that infinitesimal distance
function should look like.
Gauss proposed that
it should always
have the same
quadratic form that it
has for Euclidean distances.
For Euclidean distances,
the Pythagorean theorem
tells us that the distance
between any two points
is the sum of the squares
of the coordinate distances.
And for non-Euclidean
geometry, we generalize that
by allowing each term in
this quadratic expansion
to have its own prefactor,
and those prefactors
could be functions of position.
So g sub xx of xy is just
a function of x and y.
And g sub xy is another
function of x and y.
And g sub yy is another
And the distance
function is taken
as the sum of those three terms.
The important feature that that
quadratic form corresponds to,
which was noticed by Gauss, is
that if the distance function
has that form, it means that
even though the space is not
Euclidean and will
not obey, in general,
the axioms of
Euclidean geometry--
and in particular
the fifth postulate--
it is still true that in
a very tiny neighborhood,
it will resemble
Euclidean geometry, where
the resemblance will
become more and more exact
as you confine yourself
to tinier and tinier
neighborhoods.
And we're kind of aware
of this in everyday life.
The surface of the earth is
approximately spherical-- we'll
ignore little things like
mountains and roads and bumps,
and pretend the surface
of the Earth is spherical.
Nonetheless, the surface of
the Earth looks flat to us.
And the reason it
looks flat is that we
see only a tiny
little bit of it.
And a tiny piece of a curved
surface always looks flat.
And mathematically
speaking, the way
to introduce enough assumptions
to validate that conclusion
is to assume that the
local distance function is
a quadratic function
of this form.
And what Gauss
originally proved is
that if the distance
function is of that form,
it is always true that
in a tiny neighborhood,
to an arbitrary accuracy, you
could define new coordinates--
x prime and y prime in the
notation of this diagram--
where in terms of
the new coordinates
in the tiny neighborhood,
the distances are just
the Euclidean distances.
ds squared equals dx prime
squared plus dy prime squared.
And that's a very crucial fact
that we will be making use of,
Einstein made use
of, in the context
of general relativity,
which we'll be getting to.
OK, that finishes the review.
Any questions about anything
that we talked about last time?
OK, great.
Now what we want
to do is to go on
to apply these ideas in detail.
In one of them in particular,
build up a full description
of closed and open
universes today.
And we are going
to begin by giving
a mathematical description
of the simplest
non-Euclidean geometry
that we have available,
which is just the surface of
a sphere-- a two dimensional
sphere embedded in
three dimensions.
That is, a two
dimensional surface
embedded in a three
dimensional space,
as is intended to be
shown in that diagram.
The sphere is described
simply by x squared plus y
squared equals plus z
squared equals r squared,
where x, y, and z are just
Euclidean coordinates.
So in this case,
our curved space,
which is the surface
of the sphere,
can be embedded in a Euclidean
space of one higher dimension.
That's not always the case.
We should not pretend that
that will always be the case.
But when it is the
case, it allows
us to study that curved surface
in a very straightforward way,
because everything
is really determined
by the Euclidean geometry of the
space in which this sphere is
embedded.
Nonetheless, when
we're done formalizing
our description of the
surface of the sphere,
the goal will be to concentrate
on what Gauss called
the "inner properties," namely
the properties of the surface
itself.
And we will try to pretend
that the three dimensional
space never even existed.
It won't be required
for anything
that we'll be left
with, once we have
a solid description
of the surface itself.
And this will be very important
for what we'll be doing later.
So it is important to get
in touch with the idea
that we're going to study this
sphere, making use of the fact
that it could be embedded in
three Euclidean dimensions.
But in the end, we want to
think of it as a two dimensional
geometry, which
is non Euclidean.
OK, so our goal will
be to write down
the distance function
for some coordinization
of the surface of the sphere.
I should say at the beginning,
when this picture makes
it most obvious, that one
of the reasons we might
be interested in the surface
of a sphere, if we're
interested in cosmology, is
that we know that we're trying
to build cosmological
models that
are consistent with
homogeneity and isotropy.
Because we discussed
earlier those
are, to a very good
approximation, valid features
of the universe that
we're living in.
So the surface of a sphere
has those properties.
It's certainly
homogeneous, in the sense
that any point on the
surface of a sphere
will look exactly
like any other point.
If you were living
on that sphere,
and you didn't have
any other landmarks,
you'd have no way of knowing
where on the sphere you were.
Furthermore, it's isotropic--
same in all directions.
And when I say
that, it's important
that I really mean it in
the context of the two
dimensional surface, not the
three dimensional geometry.
So the three dimensional
geometry is isotropic.
If you sat at the
center of that sphere
and looked any direction
in three dimensions,
everything would look the same.
But that's not the isotropy
that's important for us.
We want to imagine ourselves
as two dimensional creatures
living on the surface.
And then you can imagine that
if you were a two dimensional
creature living on the
surface-- so you happen
to be at the North Pole,
because that's the easiest
to describe-- you could
imagine looking around
in a circle, 360%
available, and the world
that you'd be living in
would look exactly the same
in all directions
on the surface.
And that's the isotropy
that's important to us,
because the two
dimensional surface here
is what we're soon
going to generalize
to be our three
dimensional world.
And it's isotropy within that
world that we're talking about.
OK, so, first thing
we wanted to do
is to put coordinates on
our two dimensional surface.
If we want to ultimately
forget the third dimension
and live in the
surface, we want to have
coordinates to use
in the surface.
It's a two dimensional
surface, so it
should have two coordinates.
And when we use the
usual coordinization
of a sphere, polar
coordinates, well, it
will be two angles,
theta and phi.
And there are some
different dimensions
that are used in
different books,
but I think almost all physics
book use these conventions.
Theta is an angle
measured from the z-axis,
and phi is an angle measured
by taking the point that you're
trying to describe, which is
that dot there, projecting it
down into the xy plane,
and in the xy plane,
measuring the angle
from the x-axis.
So that's phi.
And theta and phi are the polar
coordinates describing a point
on the surface of the sphere.
And what we want to do is
describe the distance function
in terms of those polar
coordinates-- that's our goal.
OK, to describe the
distance function, what
we want to imagine is two
infinitesimally nearby points--
one described by
coordinates theta and phi,
and one described by theta plus
d theta and phi plus d phi.
So we have one point
described by theta and phi,
and another point described by
theta plus d theta, phi plus d
phi.
So the coordinate changes
are just d theta and d phi.
What we want to know
is how much distance
is undergone by moving
from the first point
to the second point.
And the easiest way to see
it is to make the changes one
at a time.
So first, we can
just vary theta.
And if we just
vary theta, we see
that the point described
by theta and phi moves
along a great circle, which
goes through the z-axis.
And the distance
that the point goes
is just an arc length as a
piece of that great circle.
And since this attended angle
is d theta, and the radius is r,
the distance of that
arc length really
just follows from the definition
of an angle in radians.
The arc length is
r times d theta,
and that's really the definition
of d theta in radians.
So if we vary theta
only, the distance ds
is just equal to
r times d theta.
Everybody happy with that?
OK.
Now if we vary phi, it's
slightly more complicated,
but not much.
If we vary phi, the
point being described
would-- if you vary phi
all the way around--
make a circle around the z-axis.
That circle does
not have radius r.
That's the one thing that may
be a little bit surprising,
until you look at the picture
and see that it's true.
The radius of that circle
is r times sine theta.
So in particular,
if theta were 0,
if you're up around the
North Pole, going around
that circle would just be
going around the point.
0 radius.
And you have maximum radius
when you're at the equator,
going all the way around.
So again, we're
going in a circle
through an angle--
in this case d phi.
So the arc length is just
the angle times the radius.
But the radius is r times
sine theta, not r itself.
So when we vary phi only, ds
is equal to r times sine theta
times d phi.
Any questions?
OK, now, the next
important thing to notice
is that these two
variations that we made
are orthogonal to each other.
When we varied phi, we moved
in the horizontal plane.
There's only motion in the x and
y directions when we vary phi.
When we vary theta, we move
in the vertical direction.
And those two vectors
are orthogonal,
as you can see from the diagram.
And because we have two
orthogonal distances
that we're adding
up, and because we're
in underlying Euclidean
space here-- we
can think of those distances
as being distances in the three
dimensional Euclidean
space that we're
embedded in-- we get to use
the Pythagorean theorem.
So putting together
these two variations,
we get ds squared is equal to
an overall factor of r squared,
times d theta squared plus sine
squared theta, d phi squared.
And that formula then
describes the metric
on the surface of a sphere.
And it describes a
non-Euclidean geometry.
And once we have
that metric, we can
forget the three
dimensional picture
that we've been
drawing, and just
think of a world
in which there are
two coordinates-- theta and
phi-- with that distance
function.
And that's the way we want
to be able to think about it.
OK, everybody happy?
OK, I want to mention,
because it is perhaps
useful in other cases, depending
on your taste of how you like
to solve problems-- the
description I just gave
of deriving this formula
was geometric, that
is, we drew pictures and
wrote down the answer
based on visualizing
the pictures.
But it can also be done
purely algebraically.
To do it purely
algebraically, one
would first write
down formulas that
relayed the angular
coordinates--
I should go back to slides.
What's going on here?
Is my computer frozen?
[INAUDIBLE] Yes?
AUDIENCE: For that
formula, are you
assuming that d theta and d phi
are really small so that you
can [INAUDIBLE] the triangle?
PROFESSOR: Yes, these are
infinitesimal separations only.
That's the key idea of Gauss.
And yes, we're
making use of that.
This formula will not
hold if d theta and d phi
were large angles.
Holds only when
they're infinitesimal.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: And then
similiarly, we
can use the line integral for
calculating the distances based
on this metric?
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's right.
If we wanted to know the
distances between two finitely
separated points, we would
construct a line between them,
and then integrate
along that line.
And by line what we mean is
the path of shortest distance,
which we'll be learning about
more next time, probably.
Those are not necessarily
easy to calculate.
In this case, they're
calculable, but not really
easy.
Any other questions?
OK, so what I wanted
to do was to look
at the definition of the
coordinate system, as now
shown on the screen.
And from that, we can
write down the relationship
between x, y, and z,
and theta and phi.
And those relationships
are that x
is equal to r times sine
theta times cosine phi.
y is equal to r times
sine theta times sine phi.
And z is equal to r
times cosine theta.
And once one writes
those formulas,
then one can just use
straightforward calculus
to get the metric,
without needing
to draw any pictures at all.
You may have wanted to draw
pictures to get these formulas,
but once you have
these formulas,
you can get that by
straightforward calculus.
I'll sketch the calculation
without writing it out in full.
But given this formula
for x, we can write down
what dx is by calculus,
by chain rule.
So dx-- it's a function
of two variables.
So it would be the partial of x,
with respect to theta, times d
theta, plus the
partial derivative
of x, with respect
to phi, times d phi.
And we'll go work out what
these partial derivatives are
if I differentiate this
with respect to theta.
The sine theta turns
into cosine theta.
So the first term becomes
r cosine theta, cosine phi,
d theta.
And then plus, from here we have
the partial of x with respect
to phi.
We just differentiate this
expression with respect to phi.
The derivative of cosine
phi is minus sine phi.
So the plus sign becomes a minus
sign-- r sine theta, sine phi d
phi.
And then I won't
continue, but we
could do the same
thing for dy and dz.
And once we have expressions
for dx, dy, and dz, we
can calculate ds squared, using
the fact again that all of this
is embedded in Euclidean space.
That's where we're starting,
although in the end,
we want to forget
that Euclidean space.
But we could still
make use of it
here, and write ds squared is
equal to dx squared, plus dy
squared, plus dz squared.
One can then plug in the
expression that we have for dx,
in terms of d theta and d phi,
and the analogous expressions
that I'm not writing
down for dy and dz.
And when one puts
them in here, one
makes lots of use
of the identity
that cosine squared plus
sine squared equals 1
And after using that identity
a number of times, what you get
when you just put
together this algebra
is exactly what we had
before-- r squared times
d theta squared, plus sine
squared theta, d phi squared.
So the important
point is that once you
have the identities that relate
these two different coordinate
systems, and if you know the
distance function in the xyz
coordinate system,
you're home free,
as far as geometry is concerned.
One could just use calculus
from there on if one wants to.
Although usually the geometric
pictures make things easier.
OK, any questions about that?
OK in that case, we are
now ready to move on,
having discussed
the two dimensional
surface of a sphere embedded
in three Euclidean dimensions.
The next thing I'd like
to do-- and this really
will be our closed
universe cosmology--
we're going to discuss
the three dimensional
surface of a sphere in
four Euclidean dimensions
by analogy.
The previous exercise
was a warm- up.
Now we want to introduce a four
dimensional Euclidean space.
So our sphere now
will obey the equation
x squared plus y squared
plus z squared plus-- we need
a new letter for our new
dimension in our four
dimensional space, and I'm
using w. x, y, z, and w.
So that equation describes
a three dimensional sphere
in a four dimensional
Euclidean space.
And our goal is to do the
same thing to that equation
that we just did to the two
dimensional sphere embedded
in a three dimensional space.
Now of course it becomes much
harder to visualize anything.
If you ask how do we do
visualize things in four
dimensions, I think probably the
best answer is that we usually
don't.
And what we're going to
take advantage of mainly
is that once you know
how to write things
in terms of equations,
you don't usually
have to visualize things.
Or if you do, you
can usually get by,
by visualizing subspaces
of the full space.
If you want to visualize
the full sphere
in some rational way, I think
the crutch that I usually use,
and that most people
use, is if you
have just one extra
dimension, in this case w,
try to think of w as
a time coordinate.
Even though it's not
really a time coordinate,
it still gives you a way
of visualizing things.
So if we think of w as
a time coordinate here,
the smallest possible value
of w would be minus r.
The maximum possible
value of w would
be plus r, consistent
with this constraint,
consistent with
being on the sphere.
So when w is equal to minus
r, the other coordinates
have to be 0 to be on the
surface of the sphere.
So you can think of
that as a sphere that's
just appearing at time minus
1, with initially 0 radius.
Then as w increases, x
squared plus y squared plus z
squared increases.
So you could think of it
sphere that starts at 0 size,
gets bigger, gets as
big as r in radius
when w equals 0 and then gets
smaller again and disappears.
So that's one way of thinking
of this four dimensional sphere.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is that
kind of like looking
at the cross sections
of the sphere?
PROFESSOR: Is that
kind of like looking
at the cross sections
of the sphere?
Exactly, yes.
One is looking at cross
sections of the sphere--
successive cross sections
at successive values of w.
And if you do it in succession,
it makes w act like a time
coordinate.
But you're right.
The fact that w is
a time coordinate
is kind of irrelevant.
You could imagine
just drawing them
on a piece of
paper in any order.
And for any fixed
value of w, you're
seeing a cross section of
what this sphere looks like.
That is how the xyz coordinates
behave for a fixed value of w.
Now to coordinatize the
surface of our sphere.
Last time we used
two coordinates,
because we had a two
dimensional surface.
This time we're going
to want to use three
coordinates, because this
is a three dimensional
surface that we're describing.
And that means that we need
at least one new coordinate.
And the new coordinate
that I'm going to introduce
will be another angle,
which I'm going to call psi.
And the angle I'm going to
define, as in this diagram,
as the angle from the
new axis, the w axis.
So psi is the angle of any
arbitrary point to the w axis.
And therefore the
w coordinate itself
is going to be r times cosine
psi, just by projecting.
And the square root of the sum
of x squared plus y squared
plus z squared is then the
other component of that vector.
And beyond the sphere,
it's easy to see
that the square root of
x squared plus y squared
plus z squared has to
be r times sine psi.
OK, now we still need
two more coordinates.
This is only one coordinate--
we want to have three.
But the two other coordinates
will just be our old friends,
theta and phi We're going
to keep theta and phi.
And in order to keep
them, what we'll
imagine doing is that for
any point on the surface
of this three dimensional sphere
of the four dimensional space,
we could imagine just
ignoring the w coordinate.
And then we have x,
y, and z-coordinates,
and we can just ask what are
the values of theta and phi
that would go with those
x, y, and z-coordinates.
So theta and phi are just
defined by quote, "projecting"
the original point into the
three dimensional xyz space,
which just means ignore the
w coordinates, look at xyz,
and ask what would be
the angular coordinates,
theta and phi, for those
values of x,y, and z.
And it's easy to take
those words I just said
and turn them into equations.
We like to write down the
analog of these equations.
But we want to have
four equations now
that will specify x, y, z, and
w as a function of our three
angles, psi, theta, and phi.
But that's not hard.
I'll show you at
the bottom with w.
w we already said is just
r times the cosine of psi.
Just coming from
the fact that psi
is defined as the angle from
the point to the w-axis,
and that's enough as
you see from the picture
to imply that w is equal
to r times cosine psi.
The other point, x,y, and z,
really just follow by induction
from what we already know.
Each of these formulas
will hold in the three
dimensional subspace,
except that r,
the radius of a sphere in the
three dimensional subspace,
is not r anymore but
is r times sine psi.
So x is equal to r
times sine psi times
what it was already--
sine theta cosine phi.
y is equal to 4 times sine
psi times sine theta sine phi.
And z is equal to r times
sine psi times cosine theta.
So I just take each
of these equations
and multiply them by sine
psi to get the new equations.
And you can
straightforwardly check--
if we take x squared plus y
squared plus z squared plus w
squared here, it makes
successive use of the identity
that sine squared plus
cosine squared equals 1.
We'll be able to show that x
squared plus y squared plus z
squared plus w squared equals r
squared, like it's supposed to.
OK, so is everybody happy
with this coordinatization?
OK, I should
mention, by the way,
that if you ever have the need
to describe a sphere in 26
dimensions or whatever, this
process easily iterates,
once you've known
how to do it once.
That is, every time you
add a new dimension,
you invent a new letter
for the new axis.
You define a new angle, which
is the angle from that access.
And then the new
coordinatization
is just to set
the new coordinate
equal to r times the
cosine of the new angle.
And then take all
the old equations
and put in an extra factor
of the sine of the new angle.
And you got it.
So you could do that as
many times as you want,
if you want to describe a
very high dimensional sphere.
We should say something about
the range of these angles.
The original angle phi--
maybe I should go back
a few slides now.
The original angle phi, as
you can see from the slide,
goes around the xy plane, so
it has a range of 0 to 2 pi.
The original angle theta is
an angle from the z-axis,
and the furthest
you could never be
away from pointing towards an
axis is pointing away from it.
And that's pi, not 2 pi.
So theta has a range of 0 to pi.
And similarly, psi
is also defined
as an angle from an axis.
So again, the furthest
you could ever
be away from pointing towards an
axis is pointing away from it.
So psi, like theta, will
have a range of 0 to pi.
And if you ever need to
coordinatize a 26 dimensional
sphere, as I just mentioned,
you keep adding new angles.
Each of the new angles
goes from 0 to pi.
Thus each new angle
was introduced
as an angle between the point
that you're trying to describe
and the new axis.
So, they're all angles
like theta and psi.
So 0 is less than phi,
is less than 2 pi.
But 0 is-- these should be less
than or equal to's-- 0 is less
than or equal to theta, is
less than or equal to pi.
And 0 is less than
or equal to psi,
is less than or equal to pi.
OK, next we want to get
the metric of our three
dimensional spherical
surface embedded in our four
dimensional Euclidean space.
And I'm going to do it by
the geometric sort of way.
I'll try to just
motivate the pieces.
There'll be some cross here
between actually algebra
and geometry.
Let's see, first
I should mention
that once you have this,
you can get the answer
by the same brute force process
that we describe, but didn't
really carry out here.
That's tedious, but
it's pretty well
guaranteed to get you the
right answer if you're
careful enough, and does not
require drawing any pictures
or having any the
visualization of the geometry,
so it does have some advantages.
But I will not do it that way.
I will do it in a
geometric sort of way,
because I think it's
easier to understand
the geometric sort of way.
So here goes.
As we did over there, we
will vary our coordinates one
at a time, and
then see how we can
combine the
different variations.
Again we'll find that they're
orthogonal to each other.
So I'll be able to combine them
just by adding the squares.
But we don't necessarily
know that the beginning.
So let's start by varying
psi, the new coordinate.
And there, things
are very simple
because our new
coordinate is just
defined as the
angle from an axis.
So if we vary psi,
the point in question
just makes a circle
around the origin,
and the circle has radius,
capital R. So the variation
if I vary psi is
just r times d psi.
So ds is equal to r times d psi.
What could be simpler?
OK, now we'll imagine varying
either theta or phi or both.
And since we already
pretty well understand
this three
dimensional subspace--
this is the previous
problem-- I'm
going to talk about varying
them simultaneously.
So vary theta and phi.
Well then we know that
ds squared is really
given by this formula.
We are just varying
theta and phi
in a three dimensional space.
The fourth direction
doesn't change in this case.
But the radius involved is not
what we originally called r.
But the radius in the
three dimensional space
is r times sine psi.
That's the square
root of x squared
plus y squared plus z squared.
So what we get is ds squared
is equal to R squared
times sine squared psi
times d theta squared
plus sine squared
theta, d phi squared.
Everybody happy with that?
OK, now I'm going to
first jump ahead and then
come back and justify
what we're doing.
But if these variations
are orthogonal-- which
I will argue shortly
that they are,
so I'm not doing
this for nothing--
if the variations
are orthogonal,
then we just add
the sum of squares
using the generalized
Pythagorean theorem.
In this case, Pythagorean
theorem in four dimensions--
that's four
Euclidean dimensions,
so we should be able to use it.
So what we get for
our final answer is
ds squared is an overall
factor of r squared,
times d psi squared plus
sine squared psi, times d
theta squared, plus sine
squared theta, d phi squared.
I just added the
sum of the squares.
Now I need to justify
this orthogonality.
OK, to do that, let me introduce
a vector notation in the four
dimensional space
of x,y z, and w.
OK, we're justifying this in
the Euclidean embedding space.
And the Euclidean embedding
space of these transformations
are orthogonal.
So let me imagine varying psi.
And then I could construct
a four dimensional vector
dr-- I'll call it
sub psi because it
arises from varying psi.
So this is the four
dimensional vector
that describes the motion of
this point r as psi is varied.
And first let me just give
these components names.
I'll call it-- rather
than repeat the r,
I'm just going to call this
d psi sub x, d psi sub y,
d psi sub z, and d psi sub w.
This is just by definition.
I'm just naming the
components of that vector.
And since the vector
already has a subscript,
I don't want to
have two subscripts.
So I've changed the
name of the vector
for writing as components.
And similarly, here
I will just vary
one of these two angles, theta
and phi I'll just vary theta,
and let you know that
varying psi is no different,
and you can easily see that.
So if I vary theta,
the variation
of r when I vary theta
will be dr sub theta.
And its components I
will just call d theta
x, d theta y, d theta
z, and d theta w.
So these are just definitions.
I haven't said any
actual facts yet.
But I've defined
these two vectors,
and given names to
their components.
And now we want to look at them
and take their dot product.
Their dot product is just a
four dimensional Euclidean dot
product.
So the dot product is just dx
times d theta d psi y d theta y
plus d psi z times d
theta z plus d-- blah.
I think we should write it.
So this actually is now a
fact about Euclidean geometry
in four dimensions.
The dot product of
these two vectors
is just equal to the
product of the x components,
plus the product of
their y components,
their z components,
plus the product of
their w components.
And now what we want to
do is to look at this sum
and argue they're 0, because
if they're orthogonal,
the dot product of two
vectors should be 0.
OK, so let me first look
at the dr sub theta vector.
OK, what do we know about it?
Well, we know that when we vary
theta, from these formulas,
w does not change--
and we can easily
see that from the
picture as well.
So d theta sub w equals 0.
And since these are
all products, that
means that this
last term vanishes,
no matter what d psi w is.
So we know we don't need
to worry about that term.
We only need to worry
about these three terms.
Now what do we know
about those three terms?
If you look at dr sub theta,
and look at its three spacial
components-- x,y,
and z-- from here,
we could see that varying theta
does the same thing to x, y,
and z as it did over here,
except a different overall
factor out front.
So in particular, what
I want to point out
is that varying
theta does not change
x squared plus y
squared plus z squared.
It leaves it constant.
So if we think of
the xyz space, we
could imagine a sphere
in the xyz space,
and varying theta always
causes a variation
that's tangential
to that sphere.
It never moves in
the radial direction.
So the three vector, defined
by d theta x, d theta y,
d theta z, is tangential in the
three dimensional subspace xyz.
Just as it was when we
didn't have a w coordinate.
The w coordinate doesn't
change anything here.
So that's a little
bit [? soluable. ?]
Are people happy with that?
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
OK.
Now we want to
look at dr sub psi,
and it will have a w
component-- d psi sub w--
but we don't care about that.
We know we don't care about
it because that piece already
dropped out of our expression.
So we want to know
what this vector looks
like in the xyz space.
We don't care about what it
looks like in the w space.
So in the xyz space, we can
look at these formulas here.
As we vary psi, x, y,
and z could change.
But they all change
by the same factor--
whatever factor psi changes by.
The same sign psi appears
in all three lines.
So changing psi can only
multiply x, y, and z all
by the same factor.
And what that means
is that if you
think of this geometrically
in the xyz space,
varying psi moves the point
only in the radial direction.
If you multiply all of the
coordinates by a constant,
you are just moving in
the radial direction.
So dr psi has the property that
when we look at only its x, y,
and z components-- d
psi x d psi y, d psi z,
it is radial in the three
dimensional subspace.
So, the sum of
these three terms--
this is what we're
trying to evaluate--
is the dot product of a radial
vector and a tangential vector.
And the dot product
of a radial vector
and the tangential
vector will always
be 0, because there are
orthogonal to each other.
Sorry for the overlap
here, but equal 0,
and that's because radial is
perpendicular to tangential.
OK, everybody happy with that?
OK if so, we have
important result now.
We have derived the metric for
the three dimensional surface
of a four dimensional sphere
embedded in four Euclidean
dimensions.
And that, in fact, is
precisely the closed universe
of cosmology.
It's the homogeneous
isotropic description
of a closed universe.
OK, next thing I want to point
out is just a definition.
An important feature of
non Euclidean geometry
and general relativity--
because they're
connected to each other--
is that there never
is a unique, useful
coordinate system.
And Euclidean spaces,
there is a unique, useful
coordinate system.
It's the Cartesian system.
Sometimes it's also useful
to use polar coordinates
or something else, but by and
large the Cartesian coordinate
system is the
natural description
of Euclidean spaces.
And the coordinates of a
Cartesian coordinate system
really are distances.
Once, however, you go
from Euclidean geometry
to non Euclidean geometry-- from
flat spaces to curved spaces--
you're usually in a
situation where there just
is no natural coordinate system.
When we invented
this psi, theta, phi,
we really made a number of
arbitrary choices there.
We could have defined
things quite differently
if we wanted to.
So in general, one has
to deal with the fact
that the coordinates no
longer represent distances,
and therefore there's
a lot of arbitrariness
in the way you choose the
coordinates in the first place.
So in particular, we
could think of psi
equals zero as the center of
our new coordinate system,
with coordinates
psi, theta, and phi.
psi equals 0 corresponds
to being along the w axis,
so it's a unique point.
When you say that
psi is equal to 0,
it no longer matters
what theta and phi are.
You're at the point w equals
r and x, y, and z equals 0.
So we can think of
that as the origin
of our new coordinate system.
And we can think of
then the value of psi
as measuring how far we
are from that origin.
So psi will become
our radial coordinate.
So thinking of it
as our sphere, psi
equals 0 we might think of as
the North Pole this sphere.
But we're also going to think of
it as the origin of psi, theta,
phi space.
And we will sometimes use
other radial variables--
other variables for the
distance from the origin.
So in particular,
another coordinate
that's very commonly
used is u, which
is just defined to be the
sine of the angle psi.
And notice that the
sine of the angle psi
shows up in a lot of equations.
So taking that as
our natural variable
is a reasonable thing
to do on occasion.
Both are useful.
If we do use this, then
we can rewrite the metric
in terms of u, instead of psi.
And in order to do
that, we just have
to know how du relates to
d psi, because the metric
is written in terms
of the differentials
of the coordinates.
So that's easy to calculate.
du would be equal to
cosine of psi d psi.
But if we're trying to
rewrite the metric solely
in terms of u, we don't want
to have to divide or multiply
by cosine psi, because that's
written in terms of psi.
But we could express
cosine psi in terms of u,
because if u equals sine
psi, then cosine psi
is the square root
of 1 minus u squared.
So I can rewrite this as
the square root of 1 minus u
squared times d psi.
And then d psi squared, which
is what appears in our metric,
can be rewritten just
using that as du squared
divided by 1 minus u squared.
And the full metric now, in
terms of the u theta and psi
coordinates, can be
written as r squared
times du squared over
1 minus u squared,
plus u squared times
d theta squared
plus sine squared
theta d phi squared.
So this is another way
of writing the metric
for this three dimensional
sphere embedded
in four Euclidean dimensions.
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The value
of u doesn't uniquely
determine a point on
the sphere, right?
Because [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Very good point.
In case you didn't
hear the question,
it was pointed out
that the value of u,
unlike the value of psi, is
not uniquely indicate a point,
because on the entire sphere,
there are two points u
for every value of sine psi--
one in the northern hemisphere
and one in the
southern hemisphere,
if we think of
hemispheres as dividing
whether w is
positive or negative.
So in fact, that's right.
If we use the u
coordinate, we should
remember that if we want to
talk about the whole sphere,
we should remember that
the whole sphere is twice
as big as what we
see if we just let
u vary between 0 and
its maximum value, 1.
u equals 1 corresponds to
the equator of this sphere.
Another point which I'd like to
make now that we've written it
this way is that writing it this
way is the easiest way to see--
although we can see
it in other ways
as well-- that if u is very
small, if we look right
in the vicinity of the origin
of our new coordinate system,
if u is very small, 1 minus
u squared is very close to 1.
The square of a small
quantity is extra small,
so this denominator
is extra close to 1.
And that means that for
very small values of u,
what we have is du squared plus
u squared times this quantity.
And this is just polar
coordinates in Euclidean space.
So for u very small, we do see
that we have a local Euclidean
space.
And that, if you
might remember, was
one of the key points
about writing the metric
as the sum of squares
in the first place.
And it's true about every point,
although the coordinate system
here only makes it
obvious about the origin.
But we know that the space
actually is homogeneous,
from the way we constructed it.
So what's true about the
origin is true about any point.
So the coordinate
system, the metric
around any point, if
you look close enough
in the vicinity of the point,
looks like a Euclidean space,
which is what we expected
from the very beginning,
but we can see it
very explicitly here.
OK.
So far, this is just geometry.
But this will be a model
for a homogeneous, isotropic
universe.
We know it's
homogeneous, we know
it's isotropic from the
way we discussed it.
When we write the
metric this way,
it's obvious that it's
isotropic about the origin,
because this construction we
know is just polar coordinates,
and we know polar
coordinates don't
really single out any direction,
even though manifestly they
look like they
do, because you're
measuring angles
from the z-axis.
But we know that really
describes an isotropic sphere.
It's not obvious that
this formula describes
a homogeneous space,
because it makes
it look like u equals
0 is a special point.
But we do know that
it did correspond
to a homogeneous space from
the way we constructed it.
It really is just a
three dimensional sphere
embedded in four
Euclidean dimensions.
And if you think of
it as the sphere,
there clearly is no special
point on the sphere.
So the homogeneity is a
feature of this metric,
but a hidden feature.
It's hard to see how
you would transform
coordinates to, for example,
put a different point
at the origin.
But it is possible, and
we know it's possible,
because of the way we
originally constructed.
And if we had to
do it, we go back
to the original construction
and actually do it.
That is, if I told you I wanted
some other point in that system
to be the origin, you
could trace it all way back
to the four dimensional
Euclidean space,
and figure out how you have
to do a rotation in that four
dimensional Euclidean space to
make the point that I told you
I wanted to be the origin
to actually be the origin.
So you'd be able to do that.
It would be some work,
but you would in fact
know how to do that.
We really do understand that
the space is homogeneous, which
is guaranteed by our
original construction.
OK.
Finish with the basic
geometry-- one more
chance to ask any
questions about it.
OK, next I want to
go on now to talk
about how this fits
into general relativity.
And here we are going to
be confronting-- actually
the only place we ever will
confront-- the issue of how
matter causes space
to curve, which
is the aspect of
general relativity
that we're not really
going to do it all.
So I'll basically just
be giving you the answer.
Although we will in fact
know enough to narrow down
the range of possible
answers, pretty much.
But there will be a
fudge factor that I'll
have to just tell you
the right answer for.
So what I want to
do now is to make
a connection between this
formalism and the model
that we already discussed of
the expanding universe whose
dynamics we derived using
Newtonian mechanics.
So using internet
Newtonian mechanics,
we introduced a
scale factor a of t.
And convinced ourselves
that a dot over a squared
is equal to 8 pi over
3 g rho, minus kc
squared over a squared.
And furthermore,
that this a of t
describes the relationship
between physical distances
and coordinate distances.
Namely, if we have objects that
are at rest in this expanding
universe, comoving objects
is the phrase usually used
to describe that.
If we have comoving objects,
the comoving objects
will sit at fixed coordinates
in our coordinate system.
And the distance
between any two of them
will be some fixed distance-- l
sub c-- a coordinate distance.
But the physical distance will
vary with time, proportional
to this scale factor.
So the physical distance
between any two points
will be a function
of time, which
is the scale factor times the
time-independent coordinate
distance.
OK, if we look at our metric
for this sphere, and say
we're going to
assume that this is
going to be the metric that
describes the space that we're
describing over here, then
clearly this r that sits out
front rescales all
of the distances.
All the distances are
proportional to r,
just as all the distances
here are proportional to a.
So that could only work
if r is proportional to a.
So that's our key
conclusion here--
that r is going to
have to vary with time,
and be proportional to a.
But we can even say
a little bit more
than that, because we can
look at dimensionality.
And here comes in handy that
I insisted from the beginning
in introducing this
idea of a notch.
The notch helps us here
to get this formula right.
The units of r-- r is just
distance-- so the units of r
are just distance
units-- and I'll
pretend that we're using meters.
It doesn't really matter what
actual units we're using,
so I'll call this m for meters.
On the other hand, a of t
comes from this formula, where
physical distances are
measured in meters,
but coordinate distances
are measured in notches,
so a is meters per notch, as
we've said many times before.
So a of t is meters per notch.
So that tells us something
about this constant
of proportionality-- it has to
have the right units to turn
meters per notch into meters.
That is, it has to
have units of notches.
Where did we get notches from?
The other thing that we know
is that the little k that
appears in the Friedman
equation, which we know
is a constant-- we also
know it's a constant that
has units of 1 over notches
squared, as we worked out
some time ago.
Units of k is 1 over
notches squared.
And that's the only
thing around that
we can find that has
units of notches,
so we're going to use that
to make the units turn out
right in this equation.
So to get the units right,
we can write it as r of t
is equal to some
constant-- actually, it's
more convenient to square
this-- r squared of t
is equal to some constant times
a squared of t, divided by k.
And now that constant
is dimensionless.
The units are all built into the
a's and the k's and everything
else.
AUDIENCE: Is the constant
multiplied by that, or--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That equals sign
was a big mistake.
Constant times a squared over k.
And that constant is
now dimensionless.
Because this is
meters squared, this
is meters squared
per notch squared,
and this is just
so the notches cancel over here.
OK, now what this
constant is really
is the statement
of how curved is
our space-- r is
really a measure
the curvature of our space-- how
curved is our space for a given
description of what
the matter is doing?
a of t is directly related to
the [INAUDIBLE] calculations
you've already done.
So this clearly is a
formula of exactly the type
that I told you we weren't
going to learn how to deal with.
We're not capable in this course
of describing the Einstein
field equations,
which determine how
matter causes a space to curve.
So I'll just tell
you the answer.
The answer is that this
constant is equal to 1.
So it's certainly
a simple answer,
but we won't be
able to derive it.
So we end up with
just r squared of t
is equal to a squared
of t, divided by k.
Now it may be useful at this
point to remind ourselves
what little k meant
in the first place.
We introduced little
k in the context
of describing a purely
Newtonian model of an expanding
universe, where we imagined
just a finite sphere of matter
expanding.
And in doing that,
we defined k to be
equal to minus 2 e
divided by c squared,
where e itself was not a
quantity that we proved
was conserved.
And it's related to an
energy, but as we discussed,
there are various ways
that you could relate it
to the energies of different
pieces of the system.
But e was given by
that expression.
And if I put this
into that, just
to see more clearly how
our discussion relates
to our Newtonian
discussion, we get
r squared is equal to a squared
of t times c squared over 2 e.
And I wrote it this way mainly
to illustrate, or demonstrate,
an important point, which
is that our calculation was
non-relativistic,
but there's a c
squared appearing
in this formula.
This c squared really just
arose from our definitions.
And if we had some
other quantity here
whose units were--
we have to sub
units of meters per second for
this formula to come out right.
If we put some
other velocity here,
then this constant would not be
1 anymore, but something else.
So saying that
this constant is 1
is saying that this
formula is meaningful.
Putting the c squared
there simplifies things.
And that in turn means
that the curvature really
is a relativistic effect.
OK, we think of
relativistic effects
as effects that disappear
as the speed of light
goes to infinity.
So this formula tells us
that as the speed of light
goes to infinity-- for
fixed values of things
like the mass density, which
are buried in a squared of t--
as the speed of light
goes to infinity for fixed
values of the mass density,
r squared goes to infinity.
Now infinity may sound
like it's backwards,
but it's the right way.
1 over r is really
the curvature.
r is the radius of
curvature of the space.
As r goes to infinity,
our curved space
looks more and more flat.
So we're saying that
if you could imagine
varying the speed of light,
as you made the speed of light
larger and larger,
this space would
become flatter and flatter.
So this curvature
of the space really
is a relativistic effect,
which is related to the fact
that the speed of light is
finite and not infinite.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, when
we replace a with that,
are we missing a minus sign?
PROFESSOR: Oh we might be, yeah.
Minus sign now fixed.
The point is that for the
case we're talking about,
e would be negative and
k would be positive.
So this formula needs an
absolute value sign in it.
Thank you.
OK, it may also be
useful to relate r
more directly to astronomical
observables, which we can do,
because we have the
Friedman equation up there,
which relates a to rho.
And a dot over a is also
the Hubble expansion rate,
so that's h squared.
So this formula
tells exactly how
to write a in terms
of rho and h squared.
And in fact, it
tells us how to write
a over the square root of k
in terms of rho and H squared.
And that's exactly what r
is-- it's a squared over k.
So putting those
equations together,
we could write r is equal to c
times the inverse of the Hubble
expansion rate, over the
square root of omega minus 1.
Where omega you would
call is equal to rho
divided by rho sub c.
And rho sub c is 3 h squared
over 8 pi-- Newton's constant.
So this formula says two things.
It says that the
radius of curvature
becomes infinite
if c were infinite.
And that says what
I already said,
that's a relativistic effect.
It also tells you the
radius of curvature
goes to 0 as omega goes to 1.
So omega approaching 1 is
the flat universe case,
which is what we've
already mumbled about,
but this formula shows
it very directly.
As omega approaches 1,
for a fixed value of h
and a fixed value of
the speed of light,
the radius of curvature
goes to infinity.
The space becomes
more and more flat.
Look, I'm just going to
write one more formula, which
is really just a redefinition,
but an important redefinition
as far as where we're
going to be going next.
And then we'll finish
today's lecture,
and continue next week.
What I wanted to do is to
put these definitions back
into the metric itself.
So we can write ds squared is
equal to a squared of t divided
by k-- which is what we
previously called r squared--
times du squared over
1 minus u squared,
plus u squared times d theta
squared plus sine squared
theta d phi squared.
And now what I want to do is
make one further redefinition
of this radial variable, which,
remember, initially was psi.
Then we let u be equal
to the sine of psi.
Now I'm going to make
one further substitution.
I'm going to let little
r be equal to u divided
by the square root of k,
to bring this k inside.
And that then is
also equal to sine
of psi, divided by
the square root of k.
And when we do that, the metric
takes a slightly simpler form.
ds squared is equal
to a squared of t
all by itself on
the outside now.
And then this, after
we factor in the k,
becomes dr squared over
1 minus k r squared,
plus r squared times
d theta squared
plus sine squared
theta, d phi squared.
And this is the form that the
metric is usually written in.
It's called the
Robertson-Walker metric.
So we've only discussed
closed universes.
I had hoped to discuss
closed and open,
but open will in fact
follow very quickly
from what we already have.
So we'll begin next time by
discussing open universes.